Sir Richard congratulations on this
effort tell us a little bit about it 648
satellites and they're all going to be
in space they will be and that's the
first constellation we also have plans
for a second consolation oh we always
always like to think ahead we shall take
it up to 2400 satellites which and it is
it's really quite a quite quite an
incredible grouping of satellites around
the world and that will enable us to
make sure that those people that there's
three billion people who don't have
internet access or Wi-Fi access or
telephony and will be able to get it and
and will be able to give it to them I
think had a much better price than they
could have got if they had actually got
access how do you get the satellites
actually up there well we have a virgin
Galactic Virgin Galactic has a
mothership and the mothership will carry
launch of one which is a sorry rocket
that we've developed and the satellites
will be in launch of one and they will
go to low Earth orbit satellite and
where they will stay for about five or
six years and and then they will fall
out and as they fall out the great thing
that about having Virgin Galactic is
within two hours of a satellite coming
out we can you know pop out again and
send replacement satellites and and so
we can keep the keep the array for you
know prefer you know as long as we want
up there and very quickly very
effectively and at a very very good
price what part of the world will
initially benefit from this and how many
satellites does it take to say bring
internet Africa um the Africa will
benefit as as will I mean as well
America and you know I mean there's a
lot of places for instance in America
that you know don't don't have internet
access and the advantage of creating a
global where
is that you know we will be able to
touch most most parts of the world and
and you know they're obviously some some
continents that need it you know much
more than others initially will it be
targeted on one continent or will it be
an attempt to do it globally we will we
will be doing it globally and then we'll
be having discussions with you know
within with the individual countries and
deciding you know you know which
countries are going to welcome is the
most and which will need us the most and
and then we'll decide where to put our
efforts but you know obviously I think
all of us who are involved in this you
know we have a you know charities and I
think if we if we can help some of the
most important countries so much the
better and that's that's something we
would you know like to prioritize if at
all possible you mentioned which
countries that will welcome you the most
I mean do you anticipate regulatory
hurdles in a lot of places as you try
and get this off the ground I don't
think so because you know there's a body
that decides who gets the slots in space
and and Greg wider our chief executive
has managed to pick up the slots over
over the last you know three or four
years and and and we will be using that
network that he's accumulated but you
still have to get permission to download
into countries and but countries will
welcome this because it costs enormous
amount to you know put put you know put
cable down and and and the quality that
we're going to be able to offer is very
similar to the quality that you'd get if
you did put cable down and and and
countries are just not willing to put it
into you know remote farms or mountain
sides or or difficult places to get are
there issues we are dealing with
encryption I mean as are in the security
of the communications to the satellite
from the ground I I very much hope not I
mean we've got a wonderful technical
team that have been working on it
and we and they assure us that all those
sorts of things have been sorted but
please don't ask me about to take the
technology but but it anyway I'm
confident that they've got all those
kinds of details right and having
Qualcomm as a partner and they they
definitely know that area backwards and
they're very happy that the team have
got it right of course when you get
2,500 satellites up there how do you
keep them from running into each other
not being too serious there's a lot of
space oh it okay I think I'm ace is big
so I think we're okay on that front what
is the the business opportunity overall
Richard I mean what do you what do you
think this could potentially be its
enormous I mean if if if we've got our
figures right and you know we're talking
about being able to offer you know
affordable internet and telephony and
you know at very competitive prices but
the the returns are very very large but
then the investments very large I mean
we're talking about you know just the
initial the initial ray of 648
satellites will set the investors back
up to about two billion dollars so and
it's a big investment but very big
returns indeed well before I let you go
I do have to say congratulations i do
understand you're a new grandfather to
none other than twins I've good
experience with twins myself